i want to talk about a surprising way
to cleanse toxic kidneys what you have
to realize is that the kidney
is just as important as the liver in
detoxification in fact they work
together because the liver does
something called phase 1 phase 2
detoxification
and this is where you have various
enzymes that are turning
fat soluble poisons
into harmless water soluble
particles so both the gallbladder with
its bile
and the kidney help to eliminate these
water soluble
particles that used to be fat soluble
poisons so if there's any problem with
the liver where you don't get this water
soluble breakdown product then it
overloads the kidney and the other parts
of the digestive tract so it's very very
important to have each detoxification
organ to be working
to share the load
so the liver gets hammered with
xenobiotics which are just like
chemicals in the environment uh
pesticides herbicides fungicides
things like that steroid byproducts
from your own body's production of
steroids that would be like estrogen
progesterone cortisol things like that
and then drugs okay medications
just hammer the liver and the kidneys
then we have glyphosate which is an
entire food supply not to mention it's
in the water it's in foods it's all over
the place then you have things like pcbs
which are chemicals in plastics so the
water bottle that you drink the the
plastic that you microwave your lunch in
all can leech out these um chemicals
and your liver and your kidney have to
deal with them so each year more
chemicals are being pumped out and our
environment is becoming more and more
toxic so our bodies are having to deal
with this and detoxify them
so the kidneys
get rid of certain protein byproducts
and eliminate urea
ammonia and uric acid and so if there's
kidney weakness those things can build
up and create
toxicity and so the kidney really is
just um a composite of
millions of tiny little
filters okay just filtering things out
and so a really good way to test these
little filters is to check something
called the gfr
glomerular filtration rate
and that just measures how fast things
are being
filtered through the kidney the kidney
has to do with heavy metals
the worst heavy metal would be cadmium
because the kidney has a very difficult
time getting rid of that heavy metal and
cadmium usually comes from smoking
because it's in the fertilizer that they
use to grow tobacco it's also in
commercial soybeans
so cadmium hits the kidney the most out
of any body tissue in fact 20 of
osteoporosis is caused by
cadmium toxicity then you have mercury
right very toxic to the kidneys um
mercury fillings which i had all mine
removed i think every single tooth in my
skull had silver mercury fillings also
when you consume uh larger fish it can
be
pretty toxic with mercury now as you age
you lose the ability to filter a
nine-year-old has like 50 percent
of kidney function compared to a 20 year
old and these
chemicals that were exposed to in the
kidney destroy the mitochondria then you
lose more and more ability to detoxify
and then these chemicals accumulate and
they recirculate through the body then
you have nsaids right so many people
around those for inflammation
before you had a good prescription but
as soon as those patents ran out they
became over the counter and so a lot of
people are taking way more of those than
they really should
and there's no long-term studies
on the chronic
exposure to nsaids on different body
tissue especially the kidney but we do
know that if you've been exposed to
nsaids over three years
it can cause irreversible kidney damage
now the other very important thing i
want to talk about
is the consumption of too much sodium
and not enough potassium
when people think about potassium they
immediately think that it's
bad for the kidneys but it's not there's
a lot of new
science that shows that potassium is
kidney protective it's called
nephroprotection
and i put a lot of the research down in
the description so you can check it out
but an average person at least in the
u.s consumes between 3.4 grams to 4.9
grams of sodium every single day that's
49 100 milligrams okay
as far as potassium goes
an average person only consumes 2.1
to 2.6 grams of potassium when they
actually need at least 4 700 milligrams
every single day and when you have too
much sodium
and not enough potassium there's three
big problems number one
you potentially can get high blood
pressure number two heart disease and
number three
chronic kidney disease you know many
doctors tell patients focus on sodium
sodium sodium but they're they don't
talk about potassium the sodium
potassium ratio is way more important
than just one of these minerals
if you have enough potassium you're
protected against the excess amount of
sodium so in reality those ratios should
be completely
reversed you should have at least twice
as much potassium as sodium and this is
mainly due because of low potassium
diets
the three things that affect you
especially the kidney when you are on a
low potassium diet is number one you get
inflammation of the kidney number two
you get a lot of oxidation and free
radical damage on the kidney
and the third thing is fibrosis of the
kidney you're basically going to lose
the function of the kidney now
the other thing that is also very
important and you may already know this
if you watch my other videos
is that the number one thing that
destroys the kidney is a high carb
diet because if you take a look at
diabetics for example
they have four main big problems
they usually always have kidney problems
because glucose
destroys the kidney filter high levels
of glucose of the kidney crave massive
oxidation and destroy the kidney that's
why diabetics have such a high risk of
being on kidney dialysis long term i
mean the big push is to control your
blood sugars
but not to control the diet
the high sugar if you're controlling the
blood glucose medications where do you
think this glucose is going when you
take the medication is it evaporating
no it's just going from one place to
another it's being shoved in different
parts of the body unless you get off
these carbs i don't care how much you
try to regulate the glucose in your
blood
it's going to create a problem in
another place
but the four places that
high glucose either being a pre-diabetic
or diabetic effect is number one the
kidney number two the brain and the
nerves
three the vascular system and the heart
and number four the eye but diabetic
nephropathy
is a very common condition with
diabetics
and it's destruction of the kidney
because you're a diabetic you have high
glucose flowing through your bloodstream
now overall the common symptoms for
kidney problems would be anemia
high blood pressure we've already talked
about that itchiness
edema foamy urine because you've lost
kidney function and if the kidneys can't
filter out the protein it starts getting
foamy and then you have ammonia breath
it's another symptom and then a metallic
taste in your mouth
and frequent urination which usually is
occurring because
you have too much glucose in the
bloodstream
this is why the best thing to do for
frequent urination
is to give up your carbs and stop
snacking at night
it produces dramatic effects within days
okay you won't be getting up through the
night i'll put that video down below
and then the last big symptom uh that
occurs with kidney problems is darker
urine okay your urine is darker brown
because you're getting more byproducts
that are going through this filter
that's damaged all right so this is the
list of what to do to start cleaning
the kidney and i think a better word for
that would be to improve the
detoxification pathways of the kidney so
number one the most important thing is
to eliminate the toxic exposure on your
kidneys so you need to start eating
cleaner or going on an organic diet
getting a water filter
making sure that you're on the least
amount of medications possible basically
eliminating the things that are
destroying the kidney and it could be
just giving up smoking and it could be
also making sure you don't consume any
more soy products right all right number
two going on a low carb diet it's going
to give the kidney a tremendous amount
of relief because now there'll be a
whole heck of a lot less oxidation going
on in the kidney all right number three
you need to correct your sodium
potassium
ratios okay now i'm not telling you to
lower your sodium all you need to do is
make sure your potassium is at least
twice as high as your sodium how do you
do that start eating more avocados start
having bigger amounts of salad
ideally between seven to ten cups every
day now if you're doing other vegetables
you don't have to do that much salad but
you need to start increasing more foods
high in potassium but potassium is
protective on the kidney
and i'm going to put all that data down
below as well all right number four if
you have a lot of kidney stress okay
you don't want to overload it with too
much protein you want to go on a
moderate protein diet
when you overload the kidneys with too
much protein you can end up with foamy
urine
you can put a little more stress on the
kidneys because your body can only deal
with so much protein it doesn't store
protein
like fat in carbohydrates it has to deal
with this excess protein so it either
has to turn it into
urea
as a waste product or it has to turn it
into glucose as fuel
so too much protein is not a good idea
for the kidney all right number five
there are foods that you should be
eating to naturally enhance
the detoxification of the kidney
and let me just go through the list
garlic garlic will increase the
clearance of urea and other and other
byproducts from the kidney then we have
asparagus okay now when you eat
asparagus you have this weird smell
going on in your urine that's not toxic
material it's something else
for another video but asparagus is
really good to help you detoxify the
kidney and then we have celery another
good detoxifier and then parsley awesome
parsley is also good to help eliminate
heavy metals from the body
cilantro is also good as well then we
get turmeric which is awesome for the
kidney
cruciferous vegetables those are good
for the liver but they're also equally
as good for the kidney berries
especially blueberries are really good
for kidney detoxification and then green
tea the phytonutrient in green tea can
really help the kidneys detoxify
effectively now if you haven't checked
out my video
on the best way to clean the liver
i think that would be appropriate check
it out right here